the Democratic Republic of Congo is a
stunning country very very beautiful
it's very lush and green
underneath the land lies some of the
richest mineral deposits in the world
but people are all living extremely poor
lives we knew that there was
considerably high number of children
working on mines we set out to film
underaged miners mining various minerals
in the DRC particularly cobalt cobalt is
a key ingredient in smartphones because
it's used in the batteries
child labor isn't a new problem but it
was very difficult to document it so we
set out to do that we went across the
region the mining region and the Congo
and we came across everyone is involved
in mining this area which is in the
shadow of a huge rich seam of minerals
thrives entirely on what protease they
get from the mine you can see how
they're living in extremely simply very
poorly yet most of what they're getting
from the mine is going to fuel the
profits of these multinational companies
who are making billions out of these
people's work
[Music]
we ended up being taken to this co-op
line in the middle of nowhere
and then we came across stall Sun and
Richard these tiny little kids
they were the smallest in the group and
they were obviously quite friendly as
well it was just amazing to what
children as young as Thor some eight
years old and rich I think at the time
was ten or eleven doing what they were
doing I mean the conditions were
horrendous Dawson just looked absolutely
miserable because he was soaked wet
through and still struggling to carry
these bags both of them were doing it
very uncomplainingly just like this is
life this is our life
[Music]
when I saw Dawson I saw a very young
child but you could just see he was an
old soul there was no child in him he
didn't have the characteristics that
children have that carefree happy nature
Richard his older friend looked a little
bit stronger but they both were
incredibly hungry yesterday we didn't
eat anything but today I don't know
maybe today there is a chance we can eat
something the image of very young
children doing very hard physical work
in really miserable conditions I think
that really struck a chord
the pictures just screamed out this is
wrong
you have these very sad but beautiful
faces streaming with water
shivering little boys he was a very
striking image
[Music]
for me it was an incredible imagery of
children not being children as a father
of three I want children to be able to
be children to play to laugh not to have
to lift 20 kg bags not to be working not
to be straining under the most
incredible conditions
we do stories and reports all around the
world every day and hardly any of them
triggers such a massive reaction it
suddenly just caught the imagination of
people all over the world you know all
different countries were writing in and
asking to help and demanding action it
was like nothing we'd ever seen there
are a number of other corporations but
Apple very quickly came out and issued a
statement saying that they were
investigating here's this enormous
multinational corporation who initially
had said they had their own processes
and so when they did start changing
things we really felt a sense of
euphoria that something had happened and
there was a little bit of change going
on there was one charity in the local
area in limba XI and we did our research
and they seemed like they were a
credible real realistic organization and
they were very keen to help and then we
had to go and find the boys this is a
quest to find the door so magician
when we decided we were going to go back
there's a question of trying to make it
through the jungle to find them which
wasn't necessarily that easy because
there are no roads there are just jungle
paths the vehicles we had were the best
brakes would fail quite regularly
I believe we did that
careering down Jules without breaks
these are the challenges of DRC car with
no brakes and no motorbike and we're
miles from anywhere
eventually the team had to get out and
walk sample for a few miles before they
found the village and eventually found
Dawson and Richard the charity's plan
was to put Richard and Dawson into
boarding school to try and give them
this tremendous new hope of an education
and therefore a future and they couldn't
do any of this without the permission of
the fathers Dawson's father was
immediately teamed for Dawson to go and
realized that it was going to change
Dawson's life forever for the better
I agreed to see my children because it's
my future my blood in this kid that you
so he
door son's father when we turned up with
the charity who were explaining to him
we can give you a son an education his
eyes lit up but he was immediately sort
of hang on you're gonna take my son away
it's quite heartbreaking because the
father had to make a decision to let go
the only thing he had in his life that
was keeping him going because his wife
had died all he had was this little boy
called Dawson and he was saying goodbye
to his best friend
[Music]
we discovered what a lovely relationship
Dawson had with his father he was very
happy for his son to be educated because
he couldn't afford it so as I said I
mean that was
[Music]
I felt the connection I thought my word
this this is so special
it's an incredible dilemma for somebody
in that situation who knows that they
want a better life for this small child
but relies on them for their livelihood
it was incredibly poignant and
heart-rending to watch them have to
separate I hadn't seen a child in Dawson
up at all that moment that he got into
the car he hadn't been in cars many
times and he'd suddenly litter
[Music]
they were very excited going off and
very excited turning up at the house
because by the time they got to the
house it was hours and hours and hours
and hours later and pitch black
all the other little boys are in this
house all came out to greet them gently
welcomed Dawson and Richard in there was
great excitement
[Music]
they were a bit nervous they had their
first meal and they were very quiet
when we first found Orson Richard they
probably hadn't eaten for a couple of
days now they had regular food and for
them that was the most astonishing thing
[Music]
then they've got taken to their bedrooms
and then they slept on a bed for the
first time what does it feel like being
on a proper bed finished again
gelatinous
occupy I feel very good deposit that's
my home I never sleep today I feel happy
to be here the change was immediate in
them
they went from dirty torn clothes with
no shoes to getting brand new uniform so
physically there was an immediate change
they suddenly became proper little
students one of the concerns about
taking the boys out of their communities
and away from their families was that
they wouldn't have enough contact with
them and there they'd be separated both
for the family's sake and for the boys
one thing that the charity is very very
good at is maintaining those links
because they want to find ways of
getting the family up on its feet so
that they can take the boys back
eventually
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a story that has a happy ending but
it is marred in utter tragedy when you
look at thousands of other children
still left in those conditions what we
hope is that it has an effect to change
the industry itself because while some
participants in that industry have
changed the way they do things the great
many won't because the business of
mining and extracting and using those
minerals is too great for them
[Music]
we need to be holding huge corporations
who make billions of pounds and dollars
every year from selling these items we
need to be asking do you know how you're
making these billions of pounds and if
you don't know why don't you know and if
you do know why aren't you doing
something about it
[Music]
I'd love to see the bald side in a
year's time I like to see when five
years time I'd like to see him in 10
years time Annette as an adult there's a
little space in my heart that he's
opened up and and
he's in there for him to kind of finally
become a child again to play without the
children his own age and not have to
lift huge sex
it falls North joiner I just hoped
throughout my life to to follow his
progress
[Music]